so let's get the latest uh on the ground
i'm joined now by defense analyst dr
alex warmsley uh alex great to see you
again um a lot of focus over the last 24
hours on this announcement from russia
that they're supposedly withdrawing from
the kiev area do we believe that that's
genuinely happening
as ali bunkel just intimated it's very
hard to tell whether this is a genuine
retrenchment ahead of potential
ceasefire talks or whether this is just
a repositioning or a resupplying um
replacing exhausted troops with fresh
ones and so on that rationale behind it
if it is taking place suggesting uh
perhaps it's to aid the tone around
peace talks do we believe that or were
they forced to do this
well it's clear that the russian
attack on ukraine has not gone the way
they anticipated it's taken much longer
to achieve any of their strategic
objectives so i think i think we have to
take this with a grain of salt at the
time um so if they're removing the focus
from kiev likely to increase it uh on
the east of ukraine which we're going to
uh dive into here and the donbass region
there marked by the black uh outer line
what are the key objectives of the
russians here in that region now well
the whole pretext for launching this
invasion some five weeks ago now was to
liberate the donbass region from what
putin and his ally said was genocide and
mistreatment of the ethnic russian
population you could see from the map
that they've only actually been able to
take about
two-thirds of the donbass region but
they want to concentrate their their
capabilities there to say they could
show that they have achieved an
objective and if they really now do
focus fully on this region is that
almost impossible for the ukrainians to
repel or might they have as much success
as they have uh back in kiev well i do
think the ukrainian forces have been
woefully underestimated by the russians
and because um the the luhansk and
donetsk regions had been
in the hands of russian separatists for
the last few years the ukrainians have
special forces there they have their
crack elite forces there ready to do
their best alex thanks so much uh for
that for now that's the latest